[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
et
ldc
[Musique]
que veux tu j'ai faim et bien cherche
les vers de terre
non je n'aime pas les vers de terre j'en
mange de temps en temps pour mes quatre
heures mais je préfère une bouillie
tiens voilà de la soupe et un peu d'eau
fraîche
merci merci tu es gentil pour être
gentil il est gentil mais vraiment l'ena
ont peu d'appétit c'est pas comme moi à
la ferme c'est moi qui enfin ne revenons
pas des souvenirs inutile
[Musique]
17 argo qui se promet que fais-tu si
loin et on poulailler tu sais où
j'habite
mais je te connais fort bien je roule
très souvent autour d'un ferme pour voir
si je trouve des oeufs
comment les yeux de mes poules on ne
peut ce qu'il y'a personne ce n'est pas
une fréquentation pour moi c'est affreux
ma crainte est si sensible que le voyou
qui a osé aux sétois l'écureuil tu n'as
pas honte de te moquer la vieux coq
fatiguée et affamée à les jeunes
d'aujourd'hui note aucune éducation eau
excuse moi mais tu effectues si loin de
ta ferme
c'est la première fois que je vois un
coq dans les parages et oui mais que
veux tu es je fuis ma ferme on me trouve
trop vieux et on veut manger
et pourtant
aytus à vue vient chez moi
d'accord
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je m'appelle nono je suis encore
célibataire tu es chez toi mange et
repose toi
la fermière appelle ainsi son petit
bruno le plus jeune de ses fils celui
qui est si mignon
oui mais moi c'est le nom l'écureuil
on y pense plus apte à faire dans la
forêt on est libre et tu seras heureux
[Musique]
oh le pauvre au jeu lui chercher un bel
épis de blé ça lui fera plaisir
madame pipi
voilà me pis le coq de la ferme et
retrouver ses yeux doux copeaux que le
farceur ce matin le maire le m'a dit
qu'ils n'étaient plus employées et je
croyais qu'il était en train de cuire
beaucoup euros
croyez-vous chère madame 12 cache-t-il
chez nono l'écureuil ils se
connaissaient dont je n'en sais rien
mais ils se connaissent maintenant
bon ce n'est pas tout il faut que
j'aille le chercher son épi de blé
à bientôt
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]